now see now I know where you're going
with that all right
Teddy never crosses the line right
nineteen years I'm knowing today he's
never crossed a lot I wouldn't work with
him nineteen years if he did anything
made me uncomfortable on time that's
longer than a lot of people live yeah I
got Maurice call me one running he could
still make it but I still got it yeah
you got this you got man Marty's would
go fight he did everything you're told
I don't know when boxing is gonna
recognize that some of these techniques
are legitimate man and I'm saying in our
last 30 bouts we've been disqualified
27 times huh that's gotta say something
I don't know what what is that something
in my mind I'm always clearly wanting to
fight that other fighters still in a
coma we speak exactly how is that not a
victory [ __ ] got a photo from a goddamn
fight messenger today seems fair time
got himself hardware how you gonna let
somebody train like that and then leave
with their belt around your waist that's
found a happy man
I see you I know you're rolling but you
want me to say something I'll proverbial
for your cameras I got nothing for you
I don't know what to do you know boxes
funny you wonder what it is that's gonna
knock you out is a left hook uppercut
isn't a shot to the body who would to
say I definitely didn't see this coming
I'll tell you this I ride a dog with
teddy and rotting